Israel has become the first country in
the world to offer a fourth dose of the
vaccine to risk groups that includes
anyone over 60 years of age it's meant
to prevent prevent the vulnerable from
the Omicron variant of the coronavirus
and the countries are also facing Rising
infection numbers Israel's government
has successfully used vaccination to
flatten the curve in the past
Delta infections fell after the country
offered a third dose people last year
and DW correspondent tenure claimer went
to a vaccination Center in Tel Aviv and
talked to people about what that fourth
job means
today was really busy lots of people are
coming after the announcement that the
fourth vaccination is now available
we worked really hard today
it's important to me to get vaccinated
to protect myself and the people around
me that's why you get the jab and I hope
others do it as well
it's very scary the Omicron variant is
spreading everywhere and since we have
the vaccines available one should get it
why am I doing it because I'm 77 and I'm
considered in this in the danger region
so uh do again I want to see my
grandchildren I want to enjoy life and
that's the way to do it for me
and we're joined Now by nadav davidovich
in Tel Aviv he is the director of the
School of Public Health at the faculty
of Health Sciences at Ben guren
University and also an advisor to the
Israeli government good evening doctor
you strongly argued for a fourth job for
vulnerable vulnerable groups how does it
help them
we are living now in unprecedented times
we need to make decision uh during
uncertainty and what we saw actually
that uh there is waning immunity very
similar to what happened after the
second dose so we see that after four
months there is a reduction of
antibodies and also breakthroughs that
we can see in the epidemiological data
and on the other hand we saw that there
is a vaccine that is very safe
so very similar to what Israel did after
the second dose we finally decided
because of the huge rise in cases that
the Wayne Community the safety of the
vaccine even though we don't have a uh
you know enough data that the normal
times would be waiting uh we decided to
finally go for uh the immunocompromise
first and now we done it also for people
that are over 60 and for healthcare
workers and so is is the Omicron variant
part of the big part of the reason for
this push
It's a combination of the waning
immunity and you drive in the cases we
are going uh to face uh really
um
thousands and thousands of new cases and
finally the danger that the healthcare
system will be overwhelmed and
especially for people that are available
um talking about even a compromise those
who are over 60 or healthcare workers
because of the winning immunity and the
safety of the vaccine even though we're
still waiting for data from study
conducted the cheaper Medical Center we
made the decision to offer it for people
of course it's not compulsory and of
course the first second and third doors
are much more important and of course
also around the globe we need to improve
vaccination rates because uh the current
situation is making things
you know it's a fertile ground for a
variants but in the current
we think it's a advice you were talking
about the situation around the globe
like can we expect the rest of the world
if they're able to afford it to follow
Israel's example with a booster each
time a new variant appears
so Israel will continue to do the
surveillance because we started our
vaccination program uh first in the
world uh we are in a more advanced
situation we're very proud to share the
data of course there is a bigger problem
about mixing nationalism we think that
it's a warning sign countries are all
together and we should be doing much
better Israel is part of the Kovacs
initiative
and of course we have the responsibility
and also uh the territorian aspect that
also Palestinians are going to be a
vaccinated but of course access is not
enough there's a lot of vaccine
hesitancy that's something that we are
working very hard and vaccine are not
going to solve the economic and social
problems so we need an integrated
approach what we call Healthy null
policies vaccines are very important but
we need to complement it with travel
measures as we've been hearing for two
years a need for a Global Response uh
thank you so much nadav davidovich Dr
davidovich in Tel Aviv for your time